j'ai ma tasse de cul mais c'est comme ça
ouais ouais c'est la série ces rapports
un épisode c'est bien que tu regardes ça
va ça va salut tout le monde c'est à
dire bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de
t'imaginer t'y connais que par longs
ballons qu on en fait ce que je voulais
se présenter ce que vous faites ou vas-y
je voulais s'est présenté à des gens ça
peut être pas vraiment parler ballon
cuisse et juliette et ses mots d'après
j'ai toujours pensé que c'était parlons
peu bah ouais ouais mais c'est vrai
s'apprête à conclure que j'ai une tasse
avec comme si elle est vrai que dans le
métro on vous appelle comme ça va mal au
cul ça va présenter on fait une chaîne
on a créé une chaîne doit une chaîne de
la nuit on a créé exactement dans la
bijouterie
non pas du tout on a créé une chaîne ya
plus d'un an qui s'appelle parlons peu
parlons cru et qui est autour d'eux on
parle de sexualité de manière
décomplexée et drôle
voilà vous avez envie de me à l'examen
des cas avec une question est d'animer
chaque fois et on invite les différents
est d'ailleurs un jour pour actu
viennent directement mesure avec plaisir
officiellement et pas georges passer
dans la rue et au bon dieu qu'est ce que
l'art devient mais vraiment normand
chercheurs ont cherché un thème parce
que c'est pas évident de trouver ton âme
à toi mais heureusement je marche
surtout pas mais je marche du parquet du
coc bat et les blagues sur les genoux
t'imagines si ya pas encore de
génériques mais ça arrive mais c'est
principe de l'émission pourrait tout à
la bonne élève et la mauvaise ici bien
sûr du bon hockey
on s'est posé la question tu imagines si
on faisait l'amour qu'une seule fois
si on avait droit à une série web on
parle d'un rapport sexuel
winnie on compare la pénétration parle
de pénétration genre sucer quelqu'un
cette tonte ça comme ça non pas pour moi
non talon team pénétration hashtag
pénétration on va se caler sur la
pénétration
sachant qu'il ya plein de façons de
faire l'amour aussi
oui elle a dit nous quels sont les
autres qui font le perds les mots et de
prendre beaucoup de plaisir et donner
beaucoup de plaisir sans payer parce
qu'on a bien sûr et bien sûr si on veut
faire avant qu'une seule fois on
résoudrait tous les problèmes de
surpopulation
pendant les premières décennies l'on
finirait par s'autodétruire au bout de
quelques siècles
enfin si lorsque l'on lorsque l'on fait
on ne porte pas de préservatif que la
femme née dans une période d'ovulation
et que les deux individus sont bien
fertile et ses amis lui parle carrément
de reproduction ah oui voilà l'acteur
maurice dit que c'est la fois fluides
non mais c'est vrai en même temps oui
parce que ça limite quand même vachement
la reproduction en fait exactement ce
qu'on parle de pénétration mais alors on
serait une population extrêmement
vieillissante way est en fait déjà il
part du principe qu'il ya des problèmes
de surpopulation c'est plus des
problèmes d'organisation de populations
parce qu'en vrai si tu sais tout le
monde allait vivre au québec il ya des
au canada du nord il ya des eaux n'y a
personne
ouais en fait ouais il faut juste y
répartir était en fait un super docu sur
arte là dessus je mettrai dans la
description
ah oui mais qui dit qu'on va les
spéculations c1 c'est peut-être pas
forcément un si gros problème que ça
excepté ya peut-être d'autres trucs mais
je vois ce qui veut dire c'est comme
bien tartiner tu vas sur une tartine
tombeur tu n'oublies pas être surpris si
on est d'abord une grosse couche de
beurre et là rien tu tartine mien dans
ce show parce que merci gilles est reine
on peut nuancer ce qui dit avec
le chemin inverse et à la procréation
médicalement assistée sauf que lui il
part du principe que en gros il faudrait
vu qu'on ferait l'amour qu'une seule
fois dans notre vie on aurait très peu
de chance mais regardez gosse alors
qu'on peut faire à voir des gosses sans
faire l'amour
oui et donc en fait ça règlerait enfin
il y aurait beaucoup moins de gosse
notamment dans les pays sous développés
qui ont pas accès aux trucs de
médicaments ainsi marine mais pas
forcément en europe aussi mais l'effet
sur et moins et puis en plus qu'on ne
développerait beaucoup plus la trace
médicalement assistée je pense d'avancer
beaucoup plus là dedans
oui parce que c'est ma foi si on serait
pas bien donc c'est vrai mais pas
partout parce qu'on pouvait faire
l'amour qu'une seule fois dans sa vie ça
veut dire qu'on aurait une chance unique
pour procréer naturellement ce serait
sûrement rester comme dans la tradition
religieuse pour célébrer le mariage et
pas avant mais avec un poids symbolique
dix fois plus lourd que j'ai pas tout
compris
j'ai passé cette nuit ce serait oui oui
c'est ça avec 1 avec un but bien sûr
toujours une maman quand l'élève mans
bat alors c'est sûr que tu fais pas ça
avec n'importe qui du coup si tu as une
fois ça peut les lui qui doit bien même
temps c est ce que est ce que vous
pourrez pas faire ça n'importe avec
n'importe qui parce que tu en fait dans
la whey ah non moi sigean qu'une fois
mais
je réfléchissais pour le sou la question
imagine si c'est pas un truc qui arrive
maintenant c'est pas genre imagine
maintenant la halle aux âges on nous dit
que vous n'avez plus qu'une fois ces
genres nenê et c'est comme ça depuis là
on peut faire les deux bon on peut faire
les deux parce qu'en fait la question
elle se pose vachement plus pour les
mecs qui font tout avec les gens qui ont
5 ans par exemple ou non et qui
regardent l'émission d'absa duquel sont
à moi simple de faire moins d'accord
allait au bal et un thank you que c'est
le côté symbolique le côté ouais mais si
si je n'ai qu'une seule fois ça veut
dire qu'il faut pas que je le fasse avec
n'importe qui ça n'existe que pour les
gens qui sont nés avec cette idée là
parce que pour moi je me dis pourquoi
pas le faire sur une envie folle tu vois
ce que je veux dire le genre cramé ta
seule fois ah non alors voilà c'est ça
en fait cessé ses shows deux mois pas
moins non oui mais quand est ce que tu
sais que c'est la bonne foi parce que je
le ferai jamais du coup à ouidah george
sand en salopette jamais quand même
voilà tu joues tu dit à cette personne
là on se connaît bien maintenant on
s'est un peu draguer elle me plaît je
crois que c'est en train de tomber
amoureux ap
ah bah tu rentres dans l'amour avant bah
oui puisque comme tu as plus qu'une fois
tu as le temps de bien savoir avant et
là tu es amoureux tu as les sentiments
et là c'est l'élu mais est ce que cela
sous-entend si on est comme ça que en
fait c'est juste
on a une seule fois dans sa vie point
oui mais on a une seule fois dans sa vie
avec des envies derrière ou genre une
fois qu'on l'a fait c'est terminé pour
ce super minutes
ah bah voilà donc ça résout le problème
en fait donc si un soir j'ai une envie
de dingue avec un mec même que je
connais pas plus que ça mais aussi en
disant que c'est la seule fois de malawi
moi je me retiens cela est rare moi je
préférais faire avec quelqu'un que
j'aime
oui moi aussi bien sûr mais où au départ
plus on en parle plus je me dis qu'en
fait il ya de grandes chances que je le
fasse jamais de ma vie parce que mais
c'est d'y être apprécié en boîte mais
c'est que tu c'est pour ça que je dis
pourquoi est ce que ça pourrait paraître
un deal à août
ce soir hier mais non le mariage il a
raison de mettre le mariage on fait
quand même même si vous divorcez oui
mais tu ne serais pas au moment où tu te
maries tu te dis pas non c'est bon je
peux divorce et tu attends quoi web va
se marier mais inconsciemment bon à lire
nos grands mères enfin moi j'ai pensé
que je dirais oui peut-être genre donc
oui maintenant je lave linge et pas
aujourd'hui après voilà les gars c'est
grave rassure en fait je trouve le
divorce est inconscient mais je pense
que oui bien sûr on se dit au pire je
peux faire je peux même si tu vas pas au
divorce auquel je faisais séparés il ya
manque des verts qui nous dit ce serait
dommage d'être précoces alors là tu en
as clé en fait c'est ça le truc c'est
que c'est pas con mais comme c'est une
terre ont parlé tout à l'heure de
pression comme c'est une telle pression
je brûle un noeud pour réussir à bander
pour ne pas accumuler trop vite pour
prendre absolument du plaisir parce que
c'est comme c'est comme à la première
fois tu prends le plus de plaisir maison
c'est ça le truc c'est pour ça que je
parlais tout à l'heure de deux moments
où tu te dis juste ce soir c'est ouf
il ya une alchimie de dengue qui m'a
pourquoi est ce que ce serait pas le
moment parce que tu sens quand même
quand ça va enfin quant à elle un désir
poupon kenyan étudie à priori même si ça
se passe pas bien il ya eu avant est
tellement ouf que ce serait cool d'aller
jusqu'au bout qui en fait attendre ce
serait systématiquement attendent un
truc qu'on peut encore plus ou fait du
coût et du joueur est déçu et ouais et
du coup te dire mais qu'est en fait je
ne sais pas ce que j'attends que tu sais
pas on sait pas puisque ce serait la
première forme c'est parce qu'on attend
donc pourquoi pas le faire sur sur une
impulsion fait à l'époque c'est reparti
sur toi tu vois la fifa il parle de la
pression est déjà culation précoce je
comprends et oui irakiens vivant de
chances que ce soit un vieux un peu trop
au goût de la spéciale j'ai bien aimé
être moi ça fait 40 ans que j'ai attendu
pour ça
je repars avec mes doigts à merci je
suis en train de penser face n'est pas
une question qui est qui et peut-être
que quelqu'un a posé la question mais
comment tu sais pas forcément fin il ya
des gens qui savent pas forcément vers
qui sont attirés sexuellement
tu as une seule fois on arrête ton
identité sexuelle a des papillons se
ranger pour toi même que tu ressembles 1
carat désir ou pas mais tu peux pas
tester une autre sexualité du repas tu
veux pas tu peux pas voir autre chose
que peu ça c'est vrai ouais ouais c'est
ouf
ou alors on est là on peint depuis tout
à l'heure on part du principe qu'on est
très été recentré qui balisent la
déception va c'est pas exactement ce que
je suis et c'est foutu c'est pas ça
c'est le ballon mais bon y'a patron pas
raison possible quoi ouais alors du coup
il ya peut-être moins de pression du
conte parler de la pression chez les
mecs qui peuvent séduire par l'assemblée
enchaînement côté performant exactement
ouais ouais c'est vrai on a trouvé un
point positif parce que william est le
combat il n'y a pas de comparaison
celles ci vont il ya plus de haouich
veut dire qu on est dans un moment mais
sa c6 sait si on est dans un monde où
cette question là elle existe que tu as
grandi avec cette idée là est vrai qu'un
et en fait ça deviendra très utilitaire
que ce serait juste pour faire pour
progresser
sachant que en plus ce serait une
méthode de mer pour procréer parce qu'il
faut que même avec l'ovulation il faut
que ça se passe bien et c'est un machin
qui aurait beaucoup plus tu sois comme
ça alors que ça marchera du premier coin
en fait même pour la coke en fait ça
servira plus à rien construit par
s'embrouiller ça très sain volée et ben
ward via ce que disait notre ami tout à
l'heure par rapport au mariage et à une
serrure il encore je pense que le
darwinisme aurait doté des femmes une
possibilité d'avoir plus de bulles pour
accoucher de plus d'un enfant par
relations sexuelles
oui oui bien sûr fait là il parle de 6 à
avait toujours existé c'est la cave même
des mamans et maintenant 60 des voix en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
alors je sais pas si vous savez mais
pour les faux jumeaux
en fait tu as plus de chances d'avoir
des faux jumeaux si dans ta famille déjà
des faux jumeaux est ce que le fait
d'avoir plusieurs revues par cycle c'est
c'est enfin ça rentre dans les gènes
c'est quelque chose génétique doit être
prédisposé à aborder et donc du coup
possiblement il y aurait beaucoup plus
de femmes qui avaient des jeunes qui
aurait ses prédispositions et du coup
qui le transmet nos d'être appelé au
décès ça serait chaud donc totalement
totalement effectivement réseau les
bébés in vitro seraient la norme et
l'eugénisme en serait au point de
bienvenue à gattaca
ouais rien pas que la fécondation in
vitro
il ya aussi l'insémination artificielle
mais je suis libre en plus c'est
intéressant parce que ça en fait il ya
peut-être des religions qui seraient
obligés de s'adapter aux qui mouraient
parce que par exemple c'est interdit
alors c'est marrant ça c'est autorisé
dans l'islam le judaïsme et chez les
protestants avec ton partenaire donc pas
qu'un donneur voilà voilà
mais par contre dans le dans le
catholicisme
certains disent quoi qu'il arrive quoi
donc que le catholicisme devrait revoir
à avoir deux trois trucs c'est sinon
c'est la fin donc c'est que et mais il y
aurait aussi une insémination
artificielle aussi des coups alors je
les gants à son ennemi trop c'est en
gros donc la fécondation du
spermatozoïde et l'ovule se fait en une
envie drouot qui mangeait les problèmes
et en finir petit pouvait être comprend
donc la cellule peuvent donc et adultes
de les futurs bébés
voilà le futur bébé on le met dans le
ventre à l'air et l'inspiration
artificiel c'est qu'en fait on va
prendre les smartphones et on va mettre
direct pour aller mettre directement
dans le vif pour aider l'inspiration et
se poster dans une mère porteuse est
notamment vrai pour la fiv taille on
peut omettre les seuls à ne pas le
mettre
c'est formidable je me mets au bout ça
serait de très bonnes solutions pour
parvenir à continuer procréer sans un
port sexuelle mais c'est ce qu'on disait
pas dramatique
il ya un peu de ça ou est-ce que vous
êtes des leurs c'est que
ouais ça serait que dans les pays
développés pour qui on pouvait coucher
qu'une seule fois dans toute sa vie il y
aurait une énorme organisation pour
optimiser cette seule fois j'en serais
forcé de le faire avec la personne la
plus apte à nous correspondent
physiquement ben ouais alors là on
arrive dans une société celle ou quoi ou
alors il autorise t déciderez que 0 fois
c'est mieux et on se taperaient des
inséminations artificielles comme des
matches on a fait une émission avec mode
qui parle de l'attirance justement alors
écoutons qui allait elle fera grand mais
c'est intéressant de voir qu'il ya une
théorie qui est controversée mais il ya
en tout cas une théorie qui dit qu' on
peu à l'aveuglé avec les phéromones être
attiré par la personne qui génétiquement
et le plus opposé nous et qui sera du
coup le plus propice pour une bonne
reproduction chômeur il ya peu je me
voilà en tout cas oui et il ya aux états
unis ont offert les phéromones partie où
les gens en fait renifle à l'amiable des
t-shirts et à la fin mais n'a le nom du
t-shirt quitta le pousse plus et c'était
justement la personne qui sera le plus
comptes actifs sexuellement parce qu'il
serait le plus éloigné de toi jane amis
du coup donc ils risquent pas d'être
présent éloigner tout ça donc c'est une
protection du corps de 1 et de deux
parce que a priori tu te mets en fin de
film avec la personne qui pourrait faire
le l'enfant le plus génétiquement viable
ouais le plus
résistant résistants gay mais tout ça
c'est des eaux alors en fait je reste
quand on a du coup on s'intéresse
beaucoup trop qu'on annule yann kersalé
récemment il ya des scientifiques qui
disent non c'est là qu'il ya plein
d'autres choses qui rentrent en compte
la les phéromones et ses skis et ce
probablement vrai mais en tout cas comme
on l'est quand vous voulez faire le
faire une autre partie sur plateau
enfin voilà on l'a on représente hicks a
exhorté à gaz ont existé il ya un bar à
paris qui va ouvrir en mai première
forum en partie à paris espère moselle
d'être avisé fluide et qui cherchent
beaucoup cela veut dire trois jours tu
donnes un t-shirt les places partent
vite surnommé joueurs n'ont en fait ces
dernières des chiadma plus tard doit
mieux faire un tennis allemand voit là
c'est carrément vu dieu et je dois
sortir le tee shirt de gens que je ne
connais pas aux écoutes
les indignés ont maintenant tu es en
galère en galère
moi je trouve ça drôle en fait chaud que
le principe est drôle après est ce que
ça marche pas on sait pas mais en tout
cas je trouve que la réflexion est un
policier mais ça rejoint ça c'est joli
et puis c'est joli une sorte qu'il est
plus jamais mon pénis de ma femme
ouais à charmant ça va sortir ou s'ils
veulent encore ça va être le mec se
dirait ok c'est parti faut que je revoie
enterré
réservé aux 6 10 qu'est la fois la balle
tirée dans l'eau cela si la femme est
consentante pour ça oui mais bien sûr
mais alors c'est une galère parce que
tous les boulangers jojo matin au petit
déj et où et les arts il apporte tout
paraît qu'il y va au taf avec ça m'a
fait bien avant puisque on sait comment
ça se passe afin de cesser c'est quand
même une vieille ne galère pour rester
hors d'une nombreuse et oui peut-être
mais moi je vois juste à côté comédie de
la très très drôle c'était son bureau
avec son ordi de tafer tout avec son
fameux côté gauche marché attend chéri
était pas moins qu'il est inespéré en
chantant qui eux-mêmes arrive comme ça
c'est drôle ça que du coup tu imagines
que la meuf tomberai enceinte alors
qu'il est il reste comme ça tu as couché
vous sortir non non ne sortirait pas
ben césarienne monsieur alors rejoindre
la petite question est ce que la
première fois peut être deux
pénétrations
ah oui en même temps une denrée peiné
parce que des coups tout rehaussé de
jours bon c'est aux scolaires je
déconnais pas pour recel et 5e
ce serait très drôle ce serait bizarre
très bizarre c'est vachement tout ça
vous a plu ou pas ouais super
intéressant j'adore cool vous n'êtes pas
seulement très bon moment génial
gl ça me fait plaisir et ben franchement
sa fermeture vient corps donc tu peux
pas invitée du bouzouki paternité
c'était le test
ouais c'est cool quand l'émission tu
veux on veut bien qu'ils reviennent
c'est comme ça ça me fait plaisir parce
que à chaque fois genre donc pareil avec
les eaux de dante idéologie avec
l'harmonie années d'études à chaque fois
ils me disent un mec si tu veux refaire
quand tu auras un cas exemplaire en tout
cas voilà je suis très content que que
ça vous a plu
susic a super con way nazis merci de
m'avoir laissé invite tous et merci les
veines dictateur sur les dossiers en
plus ses prêts pour ta maison est hantée
invitera aussi dans ma tribu et si oui
oui je veux bien julliard fera le show
et votre chaîne je l'avais dans la
description aller piquer par un peu par
l'occupant moi cette chaîne que
j'apprécie beaucoup je vous qu'à chaque
fois genre c'est un bon mélange entre
genre t'as pas un truc c'est intéressant
même temps c'est drôle et des invités
dansent un pacs et à ses collègues
j'avais un région est checké ça on se
revoit très prochainement pour un autre
image ici la question
donc je met la question et vous devez
répondre dans les commentaires la
question là voilà tu imagines si on
avait plus besoin de manger avec seb
l'afrique
merci beaucoup c'était très cool merci à
louey à 13 italiens jouent beaucoup
d'amour égalitaire avec merci pour vos
commentaires et défonce à chaque fois
c'est personnel ça défonce super
communauté ses coûts la météo merci ciao
ciao
cet homme au revoir bisous c'est long
pour des vizirs n'a droit d'en faire
plaisir ou pas plein doute plein de bd
bataille